Hi, Dr. Connors. I was wondering what is the best protocol for parasites? I have all the symptoms,
I feel very out of whack as well. So, first of all, you want to test. So, you want to do some sort
of diagnostic. So, if you have all the symptoms of parasites, a lot of symptoms that would be listed
on a website as these are symptoms of parasites, it can be symptoms of other things as well.
So, I wouldn't trust that. Now, if you didn't see if you did pass a parasite and you
know that you know that you know that's a parasite, a lot of people say, I pass these things,
I know they're parasites and if they take a picture of them or they bring them into a lab,
they're not parasites. So, you could pass things in your stool that look parasitic in nature,
but they're not parasites. It can be something you ate, it can be other things that you digested
improperly, maybe you have improper digestion of things. So, you want to get a diagnostic test.
Now, there are comprehensive stool sample tests. We have that in our Rupa lab. So, if you're a member
of one of our courses, you could order a comprehensive stool sample test. That's the most
comprehensive, hence the name, test a test for parasites in your stool. So, you're going to
parasites elsewhere. Don't always have intestinal parasites. You're going to have liver flukes,
you're going to parasites that go systemic. Then, it's more difficult to test for those things. Do
eat a cheek swab type, an etiology type test is probably a more appropriate test for those things.
However, there really isn't any being harm or foul to treat as if you have parasites.
You're making your own health care decisions here. Do I have to go and spend the
body on the test kit? I just treat that instead. When you certainly can, the product that we recommend
is the product that we private labeled. Prior to us, private label eat it, we recommended
that product all the time for a long time, probably a decade. That's our product that we
private label as para clear, hence parasite clearing parasites. It comes in a large bottle. It's
I think there's 240 capsules per bottle or something like that. And you dose it based upon your weight.
So if you have a child that's maybe six years old and only weighs 50 pounds, you'd only maybe give
them one a day. If you have an adult that weighs 150 pounds, you maybe take three a day. Or if you feel
like you want to just cleanse yourself out as an adult, you can take more. I've had people take up to
nine to 12 a day, but for a very short period of time. And then they drop it down just to kind of
cleanse themself, especially if they just got some sort of food poisoning or something like that.
Now remember, with intestinal parasites, you want to also dig to the reason why, because you might
have a climate in your intestinal tract that is prone to allowing parasites to grow and or
primarily exposure of parasites. So where do you get parasites from? Well, you get parasites from
your diet primarily. So eating foods that are infected with parasites, things like sushi, probably
the most common thing that you think of. But even with that, if you ingest a parasite, you really
you still shouldn't get parasites. You should quite honestly, if you have proper HCL
production in your stomach, you should be able to eat parasites and not get parasites.
Because if you have proper HCL in your stomach, that should be, you should have a pH of about 1.5
in the stomach itself. There's no parasites that will live beyond that. So you will have killed
everything. You can go eat sushi that's laden with parasites. And if you have proper HCL balance in
your stomach, you won't get intestinal parasites. So henceforth, you know, consuming, adding HCL to
your diet, taking HCL with your food to make sure that you have proper HCL production. And there's,
I have a whole bunch more information on that HCL helicobacter pylori, which technically is at the
parasite. It's a bacterial infection, but it's parasitic to your body in a sense that it causes so
much ill health in your gut and in your arteries. Look at those blog posts. Because go to our website
and search HCL or digest it or H pylori, you'll get to a blog post that kind of walks you through the
reason why. And I've created some really nice videos on why you should be taking HCL and why the
worst that you can do is trying to quote, unquote, alkalize your system by taking baking soda or alkalized
water. So I go into, you know, you know, maybe more depth than I need to in that category because it's
so important. So, you know, parasites are, I blogged to Facebook again for a period of time. I was
off Facebook completely. I jumped on Facebook again because I like these groups. I'm in a candy
group and a soup group and a garnered group and some of these things that I like it. But I do come across
the feed and there's a lot of misinformation in the feed, which I'm astonished. There's
practicing natural doctors or practicing natural people, that's your pathic chiropractors or something.
Sometimes giving very wrong advice and one of the most ill advised things out there is about
alkalizing your body by drinking alkalized water using baking soda in, you know, adding that to
you to water and drinking that things like that to alkalize your urine and alkalize your saliva
and then selling pH strips to test your urine and test your saliva. I have some blog posts that are
more information on that. But if you want to get parasites, then do that. I mean, by all means,
follow their advice if you like parasites because that's how you're going to get parasites. If you
alkalize your stomach, if you raise the pH of your stomach beyond a highly acidic environment,
meaning once your pH of your stomach gets to 2.0, 2.5, 3.0, that's still acidic. But the more alkaline
it becomes, the more of an environment that you've created to get parasites because there are
parasitic spores, probably even on organic food inventables, and you're going to end up with parasites if
you have an alkaline environment in your stomach. So you need a very acidic stomach in order to
protect yourself from parasitic infection. But if you think you have parasites, number one,
look at the environment. Make sure that you are taking HClzyme or our product. That HClzyme
is one of our products. But one of the products that I like best is our private labeled clear
digest because it not only has HCl, but it also has digestive enzymes. Plus it has
bile support, which a lot of people need. So anybody over 35 needs bile support.
And just to help support your gallbladder and your phase 4 detoxification pathways. So
taking clear digest 2 or 3 or more per meal is going to help alkalize your stomach, help you with
digestion, help prevent parasitic infection, help with bile support, and bile secretions for
fat digestion and help with that environment. Taking some probiotics can help with the environment
of your gut. And certainly using a product like ParaClear can be good to help bring that to balance.
I would suggest that even when you're taking a parasite killing protocol, any kind, most of them have
TH1 stimulator. So no, you should know if you have an autoimmune disorder or not. Because if you have
an autoimmune disorder, you have to be careful on how long you take those TH1 stimulants because it
can actually make your autoimmune disease worse. And one of the ways you know is if you take TH1
stimulants in like parasite products, because they're going to have garlic in them, they're going to have
oregano oil, they're going to have things that are going to be an immune stimulant. Or if you take
vitamin C and things and you feel worse when you take it, that's maybe not worse with your gut,
maybe it's going to actually help your gut, but it's going to flare your joints, your joint pain.
Or it's going to flare your exhaustion because of maybe you have antibodies to the thyroid.
So you're going to have more fatigue. Or what other maybe you're going to have more brain fog,
or you're going to, anything, anytime you stimulate and immune your immune response, and you have
antibodies to self-tissue, you will do more destruction to that self-tissue when you stimulate
that immune response. So that is without doing an antibody test, like a CyRex array 5 or array 7X
test, without doing that test and having a, you know, getting a proper diagnosis that you have
an autoimmune disease, if you stimulated your immune system and your symptoms, any symptoms in your
body got worse by stimulated your immune system, it's pretty good indication that you probably have
self- antibodies. So that would spark you to get that test. I see that in the Lyme community all
the time, people think that they have chronic Lyme meeting in their definition, they have a continued
infection. So they still have an acute infection, five years post-exposure to Burelia bacteria,
and they are constantly in the killing mode that they have to be killing this, you know, I have this
live player, I have to be killing it so they're taking, you know, cats, claw, and vitamin C protocols,
and regardless, protocols, all these immune stimulated protocols, and it makes things worse,
but they think that they're just getting a Herk Simon reaction, and it's good, they're getting
dios, so that's good, I must be killing it. Well, actually, they're just stimulating an immune response
that's destroying self-tissue even more so. So make sure you look at our autoimmune course to get
more details on that. Have a bunch of videos on the blog about autoimmune disease, if you don't want
to be flared in autoimmune response.